(chair creaks)
- [Mark] All right, Vern.
Vern,
Where'd you grow up?
Where are you from originally?
- I grew up in Crownpoint area
and (sniffs) Chinle and Many Farm area.
- [Mark] And that's here in New Mexico?
- New Mexico and Arizona.
- [Mark] And you're Navajo?
- I'm Navajo, full-blooded.
- [Mark] Tell me about your childhood,
you had both your parents
growing up as a kid?
- I had both of my parents
as I was growing up as child, yes.
- [Mark] How was your childhood?
- Fair, mediocre some days,
and some days I don't understand.
- [Mark] How would you
describe your childhood?
- At times (mumbles)
I guess, I don't know.
They (mumbles) with me.
I just was out to wanna go find...
I was curious.
I'm a curious guy,
and that's how I grew up,
having fun, playing hard,
and just getting away from-
- [Mark] What was your relationship
like with your parents?
- Parents were like (clears throat)
once I walked in the room,
I know I was gonna be
disciplined, go wash up,
clean up, we're gonna go eat.
And I remember that.
I fall in line and do what I gotta do.
Basically, I was a good boy.
Good son.
- [Mark] And then alcohol
came into the picture
for you at what age?
- About like probably 8 to 12 came in.
Yeah, but the parents were
the ones who were drinking,
not me.
I was like, "What the hell
is going on with this?
"What is this about?"
I didn't know, I had no idea.
All I know is that
I had friends up and I
look like I'm curious.
I want to know, but watch myself,
I'll have to run or somethin'.
I had fear in me,
and that basically took place for me,
watch over my sisters and my brother.
- [Mark] Did you finish high school?
- No.
- No, I didn't finish high school,
but I wanted to and I always wanted to,
and I still want to,
but then I got asked,
"Ah, forget it man, what the,
"it's just a piece of form."
Most of the people who
apply for a job anyway...
- [Mark] So today you're living
on the street here in Gallup
- Today, I was living on
the streets of Gallup.
- [Mark] How long-
- for that time being.
- [Mark] How long you've been homeless?
- Ah, well over 20 years.
- [Mark] Twenty years, and
what is the drug you use most?
Is it alcohol?
- I use alcohol and yeah, alcohol,
tobacco, marijuana,
and other drugs, I just
kinda put on the side.
I don't use it that much.
- [Mark] Alcohol is a big problem
for a lot of American Indians, correct?
- Right.
- [Mark] Is there a lot of
people from your community
that just struggle with
that, with alcoholism?
- I believe so.
You could tell and you can relate.
And I said, I know what
that guy's going through,
I know what that is.
I was a witness.
- [Mark] Have you been through
rehabs and things like that?
- I went through rehabs,
and I basically got some information,
and it was good and
boring and bad letters,
it was for the best, I
think, in the long run.
- [Mark] What's your go-to drink?
- Right now it would be
probably just a Mickey,
just one, depending on the weather.
If it's too hot,
I won't drink.
(sighs) That's it.
I'll wait till the evening
to have a couple of shots,
and I call it quits (sniffs),
from experience, eh.
- [Mark] Do you ever get into,
like I've heard about
people drinking things
like rubbing alcohol
and mouthwash and Lysol,
perfume, hairspray and
Gatorade, stuff like that.
Do you ever get into any of that stuff?
- Some of 'em, just to try,
just to be part of what the hell is it,
and I read it.
I read through the ingredients,
and I said, "Well, look at
all the other ingredients.
"This is some kind of concoction."
Yeah, I tried it.
I've always had that daring, real bumps,
just go with it, just do it.
- [Mark] You're curious?
- Curious.
I guess that would be the word.
- [Mark] Do you have children?
- I have children, yes.
- [Mark] Were you around to raise them?
- I raised 'em till about they
were going into high school,
and things went wrong.
A big wind.
A big wind came in,
and of course I was always to blame.
I take it.
If it was in the blame, then I take it.
It was me.
- [Mark] Do you still
have contact with them?
- Yeah, I try to keep in contact with 'em
as much as I can,
and sometimes make it "No"
I'm just doing this.
I don't want to down nobody's day
or somethin' like that,
but they live not too
far from here (mumbles),
and they're beautiful children, healthy.
- [Mark] In looking back at your life,
do you have any regrets?
Do you have any things
you wish you had done,
wish you hadn't done?
- Well, wishing I hadn't done,
I can let that, it's nothin',
I just let it go.
That's already gone.
What I wanted to do and didn't become,
that's irrelevant, I don't need it.
I don't even want it,
but I have no regrets.
I had a beautiful life.
It was good and bad and vice a versa.
- [Mark] How old are you today?
- I'm 58.
- 58.
- 58 years old, I was born in 1960
in Fort Defiance, Gallup, I mean-
- [Mark] Born in '60
would make you 59 or 60.
- (chuckling) Fort Defiance,
Arizona, is where I was born.
- [Mark] What do you do for money now?
- What I do for money?
Well, I do anything that I would try
to make an honest money,
and nowadays I can't even,
I don't even feel like locating
or even trying to write up a resume
or look over my blueprint.
I leave it as I lost interest.
- [Mark] You've given up hope?
- I lost interest, like,
"Man, I live it the way I want to live it.
"If I'm still alive, I'm alive."
"If I fuck that, if I have to,"
excuse my language,
"but if I have to eat
out of the garbage can,
"I'll do it.
"No pun off me."
If they don't understand that (grumbles)
maybe they don't.
- [Mark] What was the hardest
part of your life now?
- [Vern] Probably when I was younger,
when I didn't quite
understand what was going on.
What I mean by what's going on
is it's me, you know.
How come mom and dad go and break apart?
What's going on?
- [Mark] Did your parents split up?
- [Vern] I was doing my hair (mumbles).
- [Mark] In the winter, it
gets very cold out here.
How do you survive the cold winters?
- [Vern] With extra material
and basically wool, and
you'll be all right.
- [Mark] Do you see
people dying in the cold?
- [Vern] It's like, "Geez,"
I went to move 'em
and I tell 'em, "Hey, what's up man?
"Hey get up, man, you're gonna freeze.
"Want me to call in for you?
"We'll call.
"Someone will call in for ya.
"I will or they will."
- [Mark] But that happens quite a bit?
- [Vern] Yeah.
- [Mark] Are you proud of
your heritage of being Navajo?
- Hmm, I never gave it quite
deep thought about that.
I don't get all
bang ho on that stuff.
I don't even look at it as
that kind of a form or statement.
I look at it as,
Oh, I'm basically just a
native young boy turned man,
still want to learn,
still want to know things
and appreciative when I find out
about things that are
interesting I never heard.
And that's what makes...
- [Mark] If you could
live your life over again,
what would you do differently?
- (clears throat) What
would I do most differently?
Well, man, I say,
I would like to just (chuckles)
just be basic, get down to basic
and take care of everything from A to B.
If I have an appointment, hit it.
If I gotta go get my ID, get it.
If I gotta reapply something, I'll go.
- [Mark] Just being more responsible?
- Being more responsible would
be the word, yes. Thank you.
Yeah, I'd like to be more responsible.
Nowadays, I'm just laid back.
I just gave up everything.
I don't even want to hear the
radio or the news or nothing.
Yeah.
- [Mark] You just want
people to leave you alone?
- Yeah, I just basically
wanna get away from everybody,
and I knew they have problems
and I just sit there and I listen,
I talk to 'em.
And (mumbles) get a controversy and then,
yeah, we have somethin' in common.
We all have somethin' that's blocking
that past door into family.
There's always gotta be one that blocks it
always saying, "You ain't family."
"Shut up, man.
"Get out of the way.
"We're family. You just don't
know it, understand it."
Basically that's right,
but I have my mother, she's still alive.
God bless her.
- [Mark] You see your mom still?
- I'm ready to go see her though.
I'll call her, but I don't have a phone.
I have a phone but the
(indistinct) has the phone,
but I have no battery.
I don't have it no.
I gotta get me a SIM card.
I got a charger, but yeah.
So basically we've been camping
out for about like, a while,
over two months, in a certain area.
And I move up and I run
into some people that I know
that are relatives I didn't even know.
So it's a small world (chuckles).
- [Mark] All right, Vern.
Well, thank you so much
for sharing your story,
and good luck out there.
I hope you get back
together with your family.
- I do too.
I know they're doing good.
And I don't want, like I said,
I don't wanna down 'em.
But I'd like to say hello.
I love you, just wanna see what's up,
miss your home cookin',
stuff like that.
That's what I'd like.
But then again, I got to get going.
What I'm searching for?
I don't know.
Somethin' I like, though.
Somethin' I really enjoy and
I just can't find it here.
Yeah, occupation habit or hobby.
A hobby.
- [Mark] It's good to
have something you love.
- Mm-hmm (affirmative).
- [Mark] Vern, thank you very much.
- Okay. Thank you.
And can you straight?
Thank you.